[Musique]
retrouvez allons nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allô nous les missions au sein de sa
découvre la réunion ensemble d'aller
parler à l'eau alors
comme on dit
j'avais mis un mois
alors hausse annulée nous les de la
commune de saint denis et nous les plus
précisément chez les as de pique nique
de mammouth quand je ne connais pas trop
loin brûlé et nous nous ça va en
direction de la roche écrite qui tombe
bien alain gaillard petit panneau la la
roche écrite ici nous narre trois temps
il a tu connais la roche écrite lee il
est réputé parce que les oiseaux
endémiques renvoi disparaît si on était
là le fameux tu es tu
choisis en france rien que ça
si l'on retrouve mon moment
rien que la même eau regarder
[Musique]
comme si la nature ne connaît à la base
il nous reste 1
bonjour comment ça va bien vous aurez
vous même et bien habiter ici ou bien
vous êtes en vacances non on est en
vacances d'accord pourquoi pourquoi
tenir la réunion alors à produire une
question en fait on voulait rallier
authenticité et
rencontrer que les gens aient de la
randonnée dans un milieu un cadre
sauvage et préservée naturel est quelque
chose d'assez montagneux donc on a
regardé plusieurs destinations et la
réunion s'est imposé comme
hôte et comment lé nord et l'alaska lisa
ne fait pas désordre la nouvelle /
premier territoire de tutu temps venons
vous représente la seor d'accord donc si
une association qui travaille sur le
twitt ud depuis 2004 maintenant avec que
moi pas tout seul voilà lohan est fait
plier le parc national avec vous et la
non sur le premier territoire loi nf en
fait travail pour lutter contre les
espèces exotiques envahissantes dans la
forêt sur l'espace du tout de suite et
donc ils ont restauré cet habitat et
c'est intéressant parce qu'aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya inquiétude qui
s'est installée et qui seraient trop
réduit au milieu de toute cette géniale
végétation qui se régénère en fait on
voit que la forêt améliorer l'habitat de
vie du mois et désaccords génial alors
du coup à eau vous savez exactement à
lannion l'intérieur on a deux missions
on suit la population de quiétude pour
savoir comment ça évolue or la commencé
en 2004 il restait six couples au monde
l'année dernière on a fini 52 couple est
en fait on atteint ce résultat par des
actions de conservation essentiellement
de la dératisation en fait on applique
toute la population réunionnaise à venir
nous rejoindre sur des chantiers qui
dure une journée pendant deux mois donc
c'est de juillet août à aller ça peut
pousser jusqu'à septembre où les gens
viennent dans la franc avec nous et
protège d'études 8 ha en luttant contre
les rats
[Musique]
alors cette les gars ya c'est que le
sentier les vraiment propre côté
marmaille allant de la main je tenais à
déchets blague est miné et new games
ramène aussi saleh potence assez pour
nout tout l'avenir et pour le pays même
bonjour monsieur bonjour monsieur comme
moi des samoa bien aurait bien y avoir
un beau couple fait répéter alors eh ben
ici nous sommes montés département pour
nous vérifier un petit peu les chantiers
que le n9 y met en place d'accords un
des chantiers de lutte connaissait
favoriser la forêt nous travail compte
des espèces exotiques envahissantes un
brin j'ai lié un raisin marron troènes
freine
calyptus et docks lanoux essaye de faire
en sorte que des baux individus de
tamarin comme ça ils s'en sortent mieux
en faisant de la lutte il travaille
comme un travail zone par zone qui ça y
est répertorié plus que des tibétains
l'endroit n'a trop d'espèces
envahissantes allons allons allons
traiter et comment at il fait pour
traite a dit justement nous essaye de
raisonner tout partenaire avec nenê le
nf le département nena le cirad le parc
national n'a vraiment quantité de
partenaires aujourd'hui nous l'a vu
aussi la seor par exemple pour préserver
le tout de suite tous ses partenaires là
il réfléchit à faire en sorte de
travailler le plus efficacement possible
d'utiliser l'argent public plus
efficacement possible c'est à dire à
quel endroit est ce que la lutte sera le
plus efficace pour préserver notre forêt
et c'est de cette façon là que sur 40
poissons de notre île les normes à effet
cent mille hectares c'est de cette façon
là que nous parvient à identifier des
zones prioritaires où ça il faut agir en
priorité
[Musique]
et ben voilà après trois heures de
marche nous arrive au gip de la plaine
des chicots elano les à
1839 mètres d'altitude alors il faut
savoir que le gip ici lite accueil de
mou depuis
1969 à l'époque n'avait rien 12 mai
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames bonjour ici au savoir
ça vient ça va très bien alors dites moi
allez vous comme ça on descend de la
roche écrit magnifique magnifique point
de vue pas du tout le cirque c'est
magnifique le piton des neiges aussi en
passe incroyable c'est vrai oui vous
êtes senti vous êtes parti de bodio ce
matin c'est un vrai vers 5h
d'accord que vous avez dormi parce que
gitans bas c'est ça trop de pratique on
a laissé les sacs au refuge et comme
j'en ai monté léger alors moi je vais
monter là haut est-ce que j'ai une forte
chance de voir quelque chose
honnêtement
soyez honnête ça peut se dégager il
faudrait vraiment qu'il a fait recouvrir
leader
mon pays comment
la réunion ça mais nous y est mal panne
où aller
rappel respect pour mon pays il vraiment
après depuis son lit
au delà des 9 à 10 pour envoi de mon
pays
même en mairie comme
[Musique]
ôtez ben voilà après 1h30 de marche
dupuis le gîte nous la rive à
2276 mètres d'altitude à la roche écrite
malheureusement la poêle à vue bonjour
alors il ya peu la roche écrite parce
que si nous gardent bien un 2 moon
quand l'arrivée ban à la marque denon
echorouk ou du concubin narre la bienne
arrivé en tout cas la réunion lé gayar
un l'on prend le temps vise italie et
poussa rendez vous dans un prochain
épisode l'émission allons-nous cette
fois ci ne s'abatte carrés sur le terral
de sel natrue
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présentée par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]